i mean is that um you have this thing
that
that for me the missing force if you
like or the missing phenomena that we
are all missing by removing it by having
entropy
cheat number one
having order at the beginning of the
universe cheat number two and having
emergent time and emergent causation
cheats three and four
is that we're me we're ignoring the fact
that
when you've got a universe just full of
objects let's call them just atoms right
and some energy and you start to break
symmetry
that that symmetry can select
and there's this thing called selection
and you don't need biology for selection
you don't need i don't worry there's no
pan psychism here there is just the
environment can
start to be the shepherd
for the sheep if you like and then the
sheep can become the shepherd and they
switch between the two and you get
complex behavior frozen in now this is
the
point that random events are random but
they are
absolutely monumental in the trajectory
so what i mean is you go to a billiard
table and you just start moving the
balls around
the state that you'll have a number of
bounces later will become precisely
controlled by your initial conditions
and some variations
start with different initial conditions
put different energy you'll get to a
different place now imagine
that the system is able to record that
memory of what happened before
that basically physics turns into
chemical chemistry through bond
formation and complex conventory
explosion and then that process is then
harnessed when biology is invented by
matter and you have you're able to
remember what happened to you at higher
higher dimensionality and that
is what that causation from
quarks to quacks
right we can have a quote on that
from rocks to rachmaninoff yeah yeah
that's a much better you know i'm much
better at this than i am right but you
you go from this kind of non-causal
system to a causal system then act on
itself so there's two levels you get to
biology and you get causation trapped in
evolution but then when evolution
produces objects that can act on
themselves we can genetically engineer
ourselves we can play with the climate
we can play with the soil we can play
with technology you get this explosion
of further complexity and that's how it
works and i think that the universe is
literally teeming with um these engines
of causation
and it doesn't need to be we could come
to a drake occasion and god you like
earth you know the fact is there's life
everywhere the sad thing is we probably
won't be able to recognize it other than
if we use assembly theory but that's
obviously my bias right and the prop the
problem i have as a theorist here is i
invented the theory and several
experiments and what my challenge is to
disprove my own theory
with
but and the problem with the discipline
i'm in is the chemist won't even engage
with it to start with and it's taken
them a very long time i have a different
i'm sorry kurt to interrupt go ahead
no i mean it's better if i don't say
anything okay it means it's going well
okay although i do have a quick question
yeah
as for lee and for you brian what's the
definition of order that doesn't involve
entropy
because if you're saying low entropy is
order
well then that sounds like a definition
of order yet the word order was used
prior to the word entropy being invented
so this is really tough so you've asked
a really smart so i'll take a stab at it
and brian will as well you can define
information in terms of your certainty
about what's going to happen next i'll
take a coin right and i say i'm going to
flip my coin
and i have no idea i have no pri i have
no nothing to suggest that it's a
weighted coin i will assign a prior that
i'm gonna give you know 50 head or sales
and i'll collect data and they'll update
when you're that so that update
constitutes some information when you're
and that is the same type of thing you
want to have a look at an order order is
a really odd thing because order is
about registry and so i would say that
order
happens
when you have no constraints let's say
oh and you allow things to cool down so
let's just take a phase transition you
take some water vapor and you know that
water vapor to kind of um precipitate
and grow a
an ice crystal
okay and if you allow that to happen
very slowly
the the order will arise from the fact
that molecules in that ice crystal the
water molecules will take the correct
low energy
configuration to make a nice tetrahedral
symmetry and then you'll get no defects
in there and you'll produce this perfect
object that just happens because the
laws of physics give you that so order
arises when you have no or the
constraints are minimal
that's kind of a really nice definition
of order um and it's hard because lots
of people argue and they bring in it's
all anthropologic you know
my kid's bedroom is not ordered he will
claim it is right but you know so that's
and then you then frame in these
entropic and information arguments but
you say hey what is information
information is about uncertainty what is
entropy entropy is about disorder so one
way of looking at is
causation or information for me is
almost the inverse of entropy so when i
burn something
i know how much entropy has changed so
if i burn a book
i in principle or i take a book to the
event hierarchy and a black hole right
you're going to get all the information
back out talking radiation i won't be
able to count it but i should be able to
work out what it's roughly going to be
so i it tells you what i've lost it's
never told me what i have and that's why
i'm pushing so hard on this is entropy
is almost like the inverse it tells me
that i lost stuff it can never tell me
what i had
yeah i very much agree with that i would
only add on just another example think
of a pendulum clock a grandfather clock
with a pendulum swinging back and forth
in vacuum
you can use that to tell time um and
actually i think it's the minimal clock
of lee works a lot on minimal systems
and and systems that exhibit uh you know
features of the very most simple basics
in essence of the phenomena not simple
in terms of like dumb but but simple in
terms of elementary and important
so you can have this clock swing back
and forth and you can use it to tell
time i.e this you know describe order
but if and only if you you define the
direction of the arrow of time right
because a pendulum is timed translation
symmetric if i didn't tell you where it
started i swung the the plum bomb out
over here and let it go you wouldn't
know uh the absolute origin of time but
uh but you could still count time in a
parametric relative way you could say so
many cycles of the pendulum later and
you could say that's in the forward but
if the universe were you know arranged
differently the laws of physics work for
newtonian physics in the absence of heat
and so forth work uh the other way so
yes so lee's right you imply some
constraint and then you can do stuff
without imposing uh this interplay
between entropy time and order but only
if you supply at least the minimum bit
of information i.e what was the initial
condition but to get back to lee's
point i think this will go back to our
rubric that we established in the ground
rules you know when lee and i were nose
to nose at the beginning and and kurt
was like pushing us and we were like
you know at the very beginning of the
fight um
you know we we should have some
explanation of of what our priors are
and how we could change our our minds so
one thing that leah said just now and
said to me on my podcast and has said uh
in in many of his wonderful debates and
again i give him credit for his courage
this is so rare that you have a
publix-facing
scientist at the highest level regius
professor at the uk which is like
appointed by the queen so i think he has
to like taste test all her food to make
sure she doesn't die like martin reese
he tells the queen her horoscope as the
royal astronomer lee is like that level
in in in in his profession so let me say
that again prefacing with respect um lee
is basically claimed that life is
abundant
and so to me in the universe and and
he's gone so far as to make a life
detection machine which uh after his
twitter bot you know in the warm
darwinian pool registers you know um you
know i'm setting up my twitter like jack
did you know 20 years ago um after that
he's going to also you know provide the
signal coming in from the universe
autonomously generated based on
fundamental mathematical principles
connected to computational devices
turing machines
but that is predicated on this bias i
call you out i use the b word lee
you are biased that there is a life is
plentiful throughout the universe and i
have to say
you know with the drake equation which
we can write down and i give it to my
undergraduate students and and lee knows
it backwards and forwards the most
important thing in any equation lee
correct me if i'm wrong is not that you
get the answer is how you account for
your uncertainties your statistical
uncertainties which are easy to
calculate
and your systematic uncertainties which
are very very difficult i use this
example in a talk i gave in the belly of
the beast guys i went to the seti
institute which we can talk about later
i gave a talk and said what if you apply
the drake equation to the san diego zoo
where i am
and he said how many people are in the
san diego zoo right now and i go through
the calculation i come out with a number
and it's like 8 000.
and that's great except when i do the
error bars if i account for each one of
the terms that goes into the drake
equation for the san diego zoo and feel
free to estimate an example of a fermi
type problem if you don't include the
error bars it's meaningless it's
worthless so i believe that league
should say that there's 100 you know
that life is abundant but i would i want
to know his error bars and i want to
know how can he go about reducing those
error bars in other words disproving
himself rather than confirming that life
is abundant necessarily what are the
potential pitfalls traps biases
confirmation and otherwise that this
abundance detector that you have uh that
you have developed and promoted
has any degree of credulity right now
that there's a hundred percent as you
said there's a hundred percent chance
i'm closer to zero percent chance of
life in the universe again no one would
like to believe it more than me
especially intelligent aliens that could
teach us the laws of physics at the 25th
century right now so i can win that
nobel prize finally but but i want to
know i'm with you
so let me let me unpack this let me
qualify because i think i mean we're
violently agreeing so um my intuition
the way i understand how chemistry works
is i think there's life everywhere i
didn't quite say a hundred percent brian
is kind of i have you on record saying a
hundred percent i know that's fine it's
fine i'm happy to stand by i think it's
great it's like you're
you're really putting me there and you
know going me in the corner and just
throwing the punches and i would say
that um
it it is i'm i i i wouldn't say i'm
biased i'm optimistic
but if you were to say league how much
evidence do you have for life elsewhere
in the universe other nerf zero i have
zero evidence
but i would you know i could kind of say
it brian you know
hey brian let's let's set fire to
something right like i don't know some
carbon how much evidence do you have for
carbon being on fire in oxygen in the
universe you might
probably wouldn't
probably wouldn't have any right but he
knows what happens on earth and knows
how simple it is and and you could
probably go yeah i could probably
imagine some carbon being on fire
somewhere
kelvin used to think the sun was powered
with coal right but when he did the math
he just worked out and have an energy so
totally i have no evidence there's life
elsewhere in the universe zero there's
some hints there might have been life on
mars there's some hints that there might
be some interesting stuff on venus we're
excited about going to europa and
enceladus right so i just to be clear
for everyone listening zero i have zero
evidence does that mean that i'm somehow
life religious no no no no what i'm
saying is chemistry is so easy
so quick
and we there are so many missing gaps
what is the likelihood here is the
likelihood that life is just vanishing
at heart or is it that we don't actually
know what how how we store information
in chemical systems when evolution works
because i i do agree
that um
there's probably life in the universe
because life is we're using life as a
very i'm using life as a very broad
casual term for the following and i'm
saying that when there is selection
there will eventually be some kind of
evolution and that evolution will
normally get r give rise at some point
in time to a luca and that luca will go
on and brian is absolutely right there's
lots of fragile links in there and we
just don't know the point about the
drake equation however is this the drake
equation is not a law it's not really an
equation it's a kind of made up thing
but i do think that brian and i should
sit down and say okay
how many stars how many planets
what fraction of the planets are even
you know my motto here is let's allow
any planet where bonds are allowed
covalent bonds because covalent bonds
let's just let's allow life on all let's
allow all those to be lifeline so then
you know why i say where there's bond
there's hope
so that's important because as kurt
always points out you know you want to
have these no-go theorems right kurt
this is something that's a fixture on
your channel you've been paying
attention brian yeah and i'm stipulating
to you lee i'm willing to change my mind
that there is no no-go theorem um you
know so in other words the probability
is greater than zero and i should never
say zero and i didn't say zero i said i
think it's closer to zero but uh but i i
agree with you bonds the proclivity of
bonds and the facility of carbon to make
bonds and so forth um i i would say
there's lots of evidence of chemical
reaction i mean we have examples of
amino acids at high redshift you know
that we can detect uh and quasar
absorption features and we know
chemistry takes place in in distant
objects but but you know uh this main
point is well taken yeah unless i and i
continue to push back and say you know
i mean
my my my conviction is my out of my kind
of my humbleness really because
the earth isn't that special it's a rock
the solar system we've got some carbon
we've got some oxygen yeah people say oh
it's lucky that we had a cleanup that
jupiter could clean up everything for us
and all this ah i don't know we don't
know what time life emerged on earth in
100 million years it might be lucky for
us that we have intelligent life and i'm
very happy to say to you know i say to
ufo believers all the time
the chances that an intelligent lifeform
has sent ufo to earth is like i mean
it's not zero but there are other
explanations right i mean there's other
things we can do i mean i know eric
weinstein at the moment has gone a bit
kind of ufo you know let's think about
it but i think he's doing it for not not
to be disrupt well to be disruptive not
disingenuous and to get people to take
people's temperature but coming back to
this i would say i have seen no no-go
theorems for for know why life should
exist elsewhere and given them an
internal optimist will say well look
there should be it should be everywhere
but what i'm super excited about is i
have a i'm willing to make a wager brian
is still young i'm even younger
um not that much but uh um but in the
next decade or two we're gonna go to
enceladus in europa
and and titan and i'm willing to bet
that if there if we do find any evidence
of life on these
objects they will be totally different
to life on earth because they've had a
completely different history there is no
relationship whereas we might find life
on mars if we haven't put life on mars
by mistake we might find evidence of
primitive life on mars like going to
earth and seeded earth right yeah i i
agree with that i mean but that pushes
things back that's just changing the day
but let me yeah yeah exactly i mean life
on earth and life are luckily to be
coupled that's not that's nothing if we
go to mars we find earth earth-like life
i'll be happy for a day
and i'll watch the nobel prizes be given
but i'm like that hasn't told me
anything new as a scientist i want to
discover something new if i went to
enceladus i found life form based on
something that isn't rna
that would be it for me that would just
be like the most amazing event in the
universe why well if i could find
different life enceladus i could start
to frame the likelihood of alien life in
our local group okay i could think about
how we could look at making new
technologies based on living systems on
earth and really even more important in
fact i almost have the same passion that
brian has for understand the origin of
the universe
for this is that if we can make life on
earth and understand the origin of life
we might be able to start to accept that
life on earth that we have right now in
our ecosystem
is very precious and how is a thing and
we need to think about framing
this
living artifact this little cultural
you know jewel that we need to keep to
be as persistent for as long as possible
and to create maximum flourishing for
our little moral kind of
worked part in the universe right so i
think almost way if you know there are
two films i watched i know i'm talking a
lot there's two films that came out the
same year one called ad astra which was
the most depressing the brian keating
movie you know
you're just as good looking as brad pitt
you know that so and then you know and
there is another film called cosmos
which was a low-budget uk movie which i
like and you should watch them because
one basically they're both about shall
we find life and one finds life very
optimistic comes to earth and says we're
here and the other one is like miserable
there's no life anywhere and for me
i i think the difference between us is
i'm an optimist because i understand my
chemistry and i'm a chemist you're an
optimist in your field you understand
that and i'm trying to i'm trying to
borrow a bit of your
intuition and i'm trying to lend you a
bit of mind and see if we can change
each other's mind from that point of
view but you're absolutely right
i have no evidence but i have no reason
why it can't happen there is nothing
magic about life on earth